[Music]
David how are you I'm doing great dan
and I think for the open then I will
come out shirtless because Larry in
Tampa I like you think I'd like it if if
we had a pose-off though of analyst at
the mothership who's winning oh wow um
god there's gonna be a lot of last
places oh god I think I put tebow in
that conversation I guess yeah he's the
younger one and I think although I think
all the ladies would probably enjoy that
probably the most and I can think of a
lot but that what they wouldn't enjoy
but he bows probably gonna be up there
for yo its Tebow in better shape now or
when he was playing uh I don't know I
mean probably he's playing but I don't
know if he worked he wear this attire
those kids are small and the genes that
are ten times too small I think I guess
they're called skinny jeans and I'm not
really a fan of them but um I don't know
if his clothes can shrunk or he's gotten
bigger I don't know which one of the
case he's bigger than you right uh yeah
yeah he's a little bit bigger I'm like
240 I think he's got 250 yeah where he
seems a little bigger than me oh man
have you ever had broken ribs because I
Ivan heard an update on Jordy Nelson but
just the possibility of broken ribs with
that hit yesterday of can you can you
play with a protective covering around
broken ribs yes you can and I think
receivers probably have more of a chance
than linemen when you're taking on
collisions every single time obviously
after the catch you'd worry about them
but I think you can protect yourself
pretty well and nowadays do they can put
these awesome pads on you that are super
light that they become basically like
steel I mean they can really protect you
with with lightweight stuff that you
heat it and it does a good job
protecting sighs I would imagine if it
is broken wrist that he as long as he
can breathe well he would be out there
because you've seen the package often
without and they're not the same made
it's not even close to the same offer uh
I saw something yesterday bill simmons
on his podcast called out Nick Saban
called him a coward saying that he
should want a coach in the NFL compete
against the best coaches which is
tougher let me start here tougher
to win national titles in college
football or to be a successful NFL coach
well I think you first you have to
stipulate where I don't think it's
exceptionally hard to win at Alabama
like one of the greatest coaches i think
in college football history is Bill
Snyder now he doesn't have any
Championships because he the Kansas
State and if it's a tougher job
obviously Alabama's a great job to have
but also this problem is NFL's know
there are there are NFL jobs to that I
built into to be more successful a
coward is not the word that come to mind
I think smarts the word that come to
mind because Nick Saban runs the whole
Alabama program so if he's on the
practice field van and he sees as a
blade of grass at a place he probably
just says hey you know get over here
hidden Twitter grass and and it happens
within at least six minutes of him
declaring it I mean he's got a he's got
huge staff off the field if I was him I
wouldn't go anywhere I understand it's
probably the last thing he has that he
hasn't proven he you know a great coach
in the NFL but he needs one different
spots and he's proven in my opinion is
the best college coach to ever do it and
I just if I was him I'm not leaving so
the Alabama Crimson Tide because I have
everything at my access to be successful
I'm recruiting five-star kids every
single year I got a huge staff I have
complete control of everything that goes
on at the University of Alabama
everything happens through Nick if
something's going to be done it's like
uh you know Coach Saban a wheel will be
allowed to institute another psychology
Club yeah okay all right we'll do that
so how's him I think it's kind of smart
i don't i don't get that talk from bill
simmons whose career would you want Nick
Saban's or Bill Belichick well yeah I
think Nick can be super successful in
the NFL if he had the reins in the
control that Belichick has but I mean me
personally I would rather be Nick
because I think you have more say and
more shaping and molding of a kid when
they're a little bit younger do you
think whose career is more impressive
Saban or Belichick look they're the same
to me I think they're both the best in
what they do is their love and I
actually I think obviously they come
from the same tree because they work
together before Nick you know broke off
and I think they're both just as
dominant just in different
we're talking to David [ __ ] the
analyst for ESPN College GameDay they
got live coverage starting at two
eastern on the mothership lane kiffin
not being there bringing in Steve
Sarkisian at least opens up the
possibility to second guess if they lose
what do you gain or what to what you
gain with Sarkisian that you don't have
with Kiffin or what do you lose with
Kiffin that you won't have with
Sarkisian I think it's a gay now lose
day I think you gained the you gain less
distraction and you lose the distraction
because lane you know he was kind of one
foot in one foot out and you I mean the
stories that have come out about what he
was doing and what he was saying and the
stuff that was going on it just it's not
acceptable and listen this isn't this is
this is the reason this didn't didn't
work with because of like kissing this
is work mr. be smart last year this for
Tom Herman the year before Ohio State
this worked with Jim McElwain this this
process is not something that's not
doable it's not it's attainable and you
can you can go forward if everybody's
doing in the right direction doing their
jobs like they're supposed to Lane
wasn't doing that and because of that I
think he was one foot in one foot out so
I don't think you lose anything I think
it's the best of the program I think you
had to make this decision I think sark
obviously hadn't called twice since 2014
i get it i mean there's going to be a
reason to call into question the move
right now but he's also made you know
he's called national championship games
and he's won national championships and
he has a ton of experience and i think
from what I've heard this is also
something then they're using for
motivation I mean this is something like
you know listen they're saying you know
they don't we don't they don't believe
in you and this was all lane and it's
just it's just another layer that [ __ ]
to go yeah we can use this for
motivation and and try to get the best
out of our kids but I don't see having
any impact on the game there's Lane was
here and the way he was doing his
business already before I don't think it
would have been successful any worse
Clemson wins tonight by what doing what
um I think their biggest question mark
for me is defensively and I know that
sounds weird I don't I know they're
going to score points and I'm for this
is an all-time great Alabama decent
and the numbers and all that says but
then I also know that this same defense
gave up 43 to Ole Miss and this defense
isn't unbeatable and then you can't
discuss a defense it's not going to let
them score it i think clemson is going
to get theirs I think Clemson
defensively I'll get the true freshman
is 18 years old can you make him beat
you can you not cut guys loose I think
one of the best things Washington did
was Washington took away all the layups
or uh / Jalen hurts they didn't let him
shoot layups they made him shoot three
they made him go through this
progression they didn't cut people loose
and give them easy buckets I mean they
really made him work for everything he
got that's what this Clemson defense is
going to have to say I don't think it's
as high school me as it was a year ago I
think they'll go back and forth and I
think it'll be I think it'll be
entertaining a 31-27 type game can you
explain this whole Clemson in the pile
stuff is that is that is that a topic of
conversation Mike wait what is going on
here David where we're grabbing the
forbidden fruit here in a pile and can a
civilian who's never played the game
understand what goes on here I don't
think so um now listen I'm not I've been
a part of these piles and I've had
things twisted and turned that I don't
appreciate I mean I'll be completely
honest and I've had my eye gouged and
I've been punched and all that good
stuff I just never seen something like
that out in the open so much I mean
there wasn't a pow you know it's killing
you know hey doll just wait till this
gets a little bit more message before
you do something like that but I got a
kick out of bull where you know trying
to defend it boy and coming to his back
yeah you know what day we've been doing
this all year no big deal well it kind
of is dog like that's kind of gross um
no I think it was uh yeah you don't want
to know what goes on as a civilian
inside those files it's not something
that's always something that we can talk
about so I completely understand the
action but i would i would prefer not to
see that over and over again so what
happens in the Powell it's kind of like
you know what happens in Vegas stays in
Vegas just keep it in the pile dog man
but it was so blatant and then they say
well it kind of breaks the tension of a
you know of the Gambian so see rameen I
there are other ways that I could break
the tension I don't know about you David
I don't know the turn of samos tension
is broken at this point I think disagree
he's probably fellow some more Tenth
than he was hey David have fun tonight
great to talk to you again thanks for
your time no problem for she ate a big
dog all right it's such a big dog David
Pauley the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]